brody you mentioned a lot of people are
single this season
audrina admits to kissing you in the
trailer for season two
brodie and i we did kiss what exactly
happened there are there feelings there
i love the facial expression right now i
mean
you know audrey you know we adrina and i
are just very close friends
we uh we there's all we've always had
chemistry adriana and i
and and we all you know we we get along
very well we like to stay up late
talk and hang out i mean you have to
kind of you have to watch to see what
happens with that
are are there feelings there now are you
single now
there's always feelings for audrina and
yes i am single
okay the single ready to mingle maybe
with audrina yeah
i mean you never know it even rhymes huh
yeah exactly you can do whatever you
want as long as with audrina
yeah frankie brandon do you guys ship
this possible
romance i've been pushing for it this
whole time
when are you here yeah i've been in
there with frankie
that's a happy ever after right
audrina's hot what can i say
it's beautiful i always thought i said
because you guys
talk wait i've been like you guys can i
can't carry on a conversation like that
as long as you guys talk with anybody so
i was like these guys are either going
to like hook up once
and do like do whatever or never hook up
or get married
you know get married whoa
funny she's like your best friend like
i've never seen anybody talk for so long
in my life
i have a lot of love for audrina okay
i've been through a lot
she's a good girl audrina you admit to
kissing brody
in the trailer for a season
i just talked to brody and he talked
about your guys's chemistry
that you have on your end what happened
there what led to that
kiss we've always had chemistry and
we respect each other and we could stay
up for hours and just keep talking and
we have the best time together i feel
like we'll always be in each other's
lives
and i'll have to see what happens
what'd brody say what wrote what did
brody
he said you're i think he said you're
beautiful he talked about your guys's
chemistry
frankie wants you guys to get married so
there was
a lot uh there's a lot riding on this
possible
relationship yeah this whole
conversation has been had
many times on the show so you guys will
get to see and hear it all
watch out we'll do it she'll do it
i swear she'll do it like that
justin how did you feel about her kiss
with brody
i didn't know anything i was just kind
of aloof about it i know they hang out
quite a bit and i know that they always
talk but i mean i never seen
anything in action myself if it did then
kudos to them
are you looking for that serious
long-term relationship
a marriage again not to be honest
right now i'm my focus is that's not my
priority
on the show it was fun um but outside of
the show like i'm not
actively looking for someone to date or
marry right now i'm just kind of
embracing the moment with my daughter
and just getting back to real life again
caitlyn
audrina admits to kissing brody in the
trailer for season two
how did you personally feel about that
um well i think this is one of those
things where they're gonna say they want
me to
tell you you're gonna have to watch the
show to find out but you know uh we've
all been friends for a very long time so
there are certainly a lot of
um challenging dynamics that happen this
season okay about it
[Music]
you